>> HEY, HEY, HOLD THE DOOR --
>> WOAH, WOAH.
>> YOU'RE A MAN.
AND MEN SWEAT.
IN ALL SORTS OF SITUATIONS.
>> YEAH, I'M A GUY.
THE WAY I SWEAT MY REGULAR
DEODORANT JUST WASN'T CUTTING IT
ANYMORE.
I WORK HARD AND I PLAY HARD, AND
SOMETHING'S COMING OUT ABOUT ME
REAL SOON BECAUSE I'M NEXT.
>> INTRODUCING NEXT, THE ONLY
ANTIPERSPIRANT FOR MEN WHO ARE
FEELING THE HEAT BECAUSE THEIR
TIME'S UP.
>> MY LINE OF WORK, SWEAT COMES
WITH JOB.
AND EVER SINCE THOSE RUMORS CAME
OUT ABOUT ME, IT GOT A LOT
WORSE.
HEY, HOW'S EVERYBODY DOING
TONIGHT?
[ CELL PHONES CHIME ]
OH, BOY.
IT'S HAPPENING.
BUT NOT UNDER HERE.
>> AS AN ACTOR, I NEED SOMETHING
THAT WILL KEEP WORKING WITH ME
BECAUSE NO ONE ELSE WILL.
>> LOTS OF WOMEN ARE BRAVE, THIS
ONE IS A LIAR, AND NO COMMENT.
>> NEXT IS FORMULATED WITH
CLINICAL STRENGTH
ANTIPERSPIRANT.
AND A JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
KLONOPIN BECAUSE THESE NEXT FEW
WEEKS ARE GOING STINK.
>> YOU'RE DISGUSTING.
>> BUT MY PITS AREN'T.
I GOT FIRED.
>> NEXT, BROUGHT TO YOU BY --
[ CELL PHONE CHIMES ]
OH, BOY, THEY GOT ME.